maybe we'll do it good yeah um first of
all I did want to say congratulations on
the movie I loved it
you guys did a fantastic job and amount
Wow um thank you that's nice one of the
things so I was at the press conference
yesterday and you and I loved the Easter
eggs that are in the Pixar movies and
hearing what's in the antique store
could you talk a little bit about the
Easter eggs in the film and the antique
store yeah I mean we've got this digital
back lot of everything ever created at
Pixar that you can bring up and and so
arse art and sets team really dug deep
to bring to look into everything that's
ever been any film and to try to select
things that were appropriate what it
makes sense to sell it you'll see this
via what would you see in an antique
store and sometimes I'm pushing the
limits on what that would be sometimes
there are things that are for example
Elliott and Carl's house from up the
house that was picked up with balloons
has been shrunken down and is now a doll
house for sale in the store so there's
things you'll recognize but not in the
ways that you'd think you monsters inc
scream-can not probably something you
would see in an into you can buy one
it's in this one second chance and peace
well my thing is that with Disney now
owning the world and all the IP in the
universe kidding aside can you put in
other things can the animators sort of
hide it and just not tell anyone well we
do should even talk about this there is
a I'm thinking Tron or Star Wars well
there is a Star Wars reference I don't
know if you caught it but yeah there's a
scene where we you get to see the
original some of the original Kenner
Star Wars toys because those ones we
grew up playing with and so I was like
those have to be in this movie and they
you can see them for a split second in
the pinball machine
I loved the pinball machine in the movie
I'm a huge pimple thing uh I'm always
curious about deleted scenes I could go
on in six different directions but what
was the last thing you cut out of the
film and why whoa
the last thing man do you remember the
very last thing but one of the last
thing and alas from what the deleted
scenes that were carved out that we're
kind of
significant maybe one of those you know
I honestly can't hurt I will tell you
that I remember we did so many different
versions the opening of this movie from
day one it just was like let's try it
scene this and changing it and fantasy
version or a real one or different like
with Andy or Mont so there's just so
many different versions one of them was
that was a zombie musical fantasy play
time that bonnie was having that was a
pretty wonder if it was Andy who started
off as a zombie thing and he realized
was Andy playing and then it turned into
a musical and it was because his sister
mall running and started playing along
with them and so the toys were even kind
of confused as to what's my last thing
for you I think that it's it's honest
honestly a visual masterpiece
it looks so insane the technology what
you did visually in this movie can you
talk a little bit about the technology
involved in pushing the boundaries
because there are shots that are like my
jaw was on the ground I have no idea how
to even do this stuff you know the yeah
Pixar is always just pushing the limits
on on technology and what the render
farm can handle and this is no exception
we had a technical team of just
brilliant minds that came together to
try to see what amount of visual detail
we could kind of get away with huge
amount of effort went into that opening
scene probably 2/3 of our effects
department's budget went into making
that opening scene with the rainstorm
just to make it as stunning as it could
be they're geniuses embeds I remember
talking about this opening scene we
don't want to feel so dangerous to these
toys and they're like got it did he come
back as how's this rain look oh my god
looks amazing you know so they're all
they're so good at what they do and it
just helps they support the story in
such a great way